shut up you [ __ ]
why you say that because she's getting
my nerves
ah
cardi b's daughter culture just called
her out for cursing and it's the cutest
thing you'll hear all day
she's so cute i love her the 29 year old
rapper hit the kitchen with her
three-year-old daughter for a little
mommy daughter baking sesh on tuesday
night and shared the adventure on her
insta story i spread it all around
all right you gotta
you gotta
you gotta
[Music]
i will come
cute right and culture was loving it
and now you could stir it but you gotta
stir it very easy and a nice motion okay
okay ready
well it was relaxing until the family
dog started barking
shut up you [ __ ]
why'd you say that
yeah culture straight up called out her
mom for her choice of words and it's so
cute we gotta run that back one more
time
shut up you [ __ ]
why are you saying that because she's
getting my nerves
ah
and despite the canine interruption
their brownies came out of the oven a
masterpiece
nice moist delicious
oh snappity snap snap after that the
dynamic duo had a little tv party in bed
mommy's not there but that's mommy and
her friend song
hey
don't be look good
culture watching a 2018 episode of the x
factor uk where the contestants just so
happened to be singing what else
diamonds
cardi b
can't tell me nothing
i changed the game
bruno mars's track finesse featuring the
grammy winner
let me see
mommy's not there but that's mommy and
her friend song
hey
don't they look good together
cause i will take care of you
the sweet moment comes just a few weeks
after cardi gave fans a heavy dose of
cuteness sharing a first look at her and
offset's eight-month-old baby boy i just
get too emotional when it comes to have
kids
after months of keeping their little one
off social media the migos rapper
revealed their bundle of joy's name wave
set cephas i already fell in love
the way that he was a dad he's really
good that same day wave made his debut
on cardi's instagram with these snaps
sitting in a comfy rocker dressed to
impress in a baby blue puffer jacket
matching beanie and white kicks complete
with an iced out chain
of course it's no secret that cardi
loves being a mama to wave and culture
you like your culture
[Music]
i love everything about motherhood i
like i like everything like it's just a
different feeling it's a lot but i love
everything
just check out what she told et about
mommyhood back in 2019.
what does it mean to be a mother it
means everything it's it's like a
feeling that it's indescribable
it's like
love joy it's a switch
you know what i'm saying it's like an
automatic smile it's everything
[Music]
you